hello and welcome to Rochford District
matters the magazine produced by the
council for its residents this is the
Autumn
edition in this Edition are articles on
the Rochford Art Trail funds to ease
congestion changes to parking charges
the annual report
20134 a D-Day hero remembers keeping us
safe and much more but the first item is
registering to
vote your vote matters make sure you're
in all residents should have received a
letter last month informing them of the
change to the Electoral registration
system a move from the old head of
household registration system to
individual electoral
registration most Rood District
residents were automatically transferred
to the new electoral register however
some will have received a letter asking
for more information to enable them to
move onto the new registration
system anyone who received a letter
asking them to update their details can
either register online at
www.gov.uk SL register to vote you can
register by phone on
31818 7 or fill in the registration form
that was attached to your letter when
you register you will be asked for both
your National Insurance number and your
date of birth if you haven't received a
letter or if you have any other
questions contact the elections team on
31818 7 or email elections
atford.com
over 25 years old living in the Rochford
District learn the basics of different
types of software how to email friends
and family how to browse the internet
and much more you don't need to know
anything about computers there are two
five we informal courses to our sessions
running one after the other course one
keeping in contact is the place to start
if you are an absolute beginner course
two getting more from Computing if you
want to learn more
you can take one or both courses but you
must take course one first training for
people in their own homes who have
Mobility or access problems this is not
a course but is designed to assist with
difficulties on a specific aspect it's
not necessary to have attended the
courses before but it is aimed at
helping with any part of the project
there are small fees for the computer
courses and home visits please ask for
details for more information visit ravs
105a High Street ra ss67 QA Monday to
Thursday between 9 and 300 p.m. call us
on
727965 Helping Hands to support our
community Rochford and Ry cab is
enhancing services for residents by
modernizing its way of working
additional telephone operators are being
trained advice and information via email
introduced and an Outreach service is
being developed to deliver this enhanced
service more volunteers are needed
training is provided so everyone one
will be
considered for more information call
6471 or C
www. advice
360.org
cab offers free confidential advice on a
range of issues at the Rochford office
is in backlane Rochford
post code ss41 a y they're open Tuesday
and Thursday from 10: a.m. to 2 p.m. at
ra it's the Civic Suite hotley Road R
ss6 8 EB they're open Monday Thursday
and Friday from 10:00 a.m. to 2:00 p.m.
you can phone them
47808 Monday to Friday between 9:30 a.m.
and 400
p.m. the Rochford Art Trail takes place
from Thursday the 18th to Saturday the
27th of
September visit rushford's award-winning
Art Trail to discover temporary
exhibitions of art and crafts in shops
windows and public buildings visit the
Facebook page for up-to-date information
including guided tours workshops demos
and a popup
Marketplace and here are the venues and
exhibiting
artists the Rochford Hotel will host
various artists but only between the
22nd and the 25th of
September care Mark there will be Sue
gash The Beehive Julia Tanner Ellis
lorri wisman number one open Arts dive
Odyssey Steve Lodge Odell's coffee shop
John Gentry mark March hairs and monkey
uncles Rochford silversmith group
Premier Wills Clare Bartlett Terren
mendo's Opticians Beverly folkard the
great wooo Aiden
Saunders Rochford Library Sally chiner
ree Ferman and King Edmund school art
student the faith store Anne bacon
Cara's choices Richard Argent Mia
Elizabeth Kerrie Baker DAV and Tessa
Frampton Rochford Furnishing Keith
gravestock Grace's attic Max doing
Rochford Hospital open Arts
whittingham's Richard Argent and the
Rochford 100 golf club Liam
O'Hurley and please note that some of
these venues have artwork displayed in
Windows and can be viewed from the
street only now you can visit the
website for more details on WW ww.
Rochford
dog. slart tril or on Facebook
www.facebook.com/
artrail or follow us on Twitter at
Rochford arts for the latest
updates environment allocations Plan
update the council adopted the
allocations plan in February of this
year this plan sets out where different
forms of development will and will not
be supported in the district for
different uses including homes
businesses schools and Open Spaces it
will be a key part of the consideration
of any planning applications made to the
council the plan follows on from the
Rochford core strategy which was adopted
in December 2011 and set out General
locations for development this plan can
be accessed at
www.ford.com .
gov.uk
allocations a member of the public has
launched a legal challenge against the
adoption of the allocations plan the
challenge was heard in the high court
over the course of two days but a
further day will be necessary this is
expected to be in
October when will we find out the result
of the legal challenge the council will
have to wait for the Judgment of the
court and we have not been given a time
scale for this what happens if the legal
challenge is successful a number of
things could happen if the legal
challenge is successful depending on the
details of the Judgment it could be the
case that all the policies in the
allocations plan are quashed deleted or
just some of them the legal challenge
seeks to quash the whole of the
allocation's plan but the focus has been
on the site for new housing north of
London Road Ry and The Travelers site at
mellin Farm if these two aspects were to
be quashed the council would need to
look again at identifying sites the
sites would still be required to conform
to the core strategy the council would
still be required to identify a site for
550 dwellings to the north of London
Road R but the policies and the exact
site boundary might be different with
the traveler site the council would
still be required to allocate land for
this use and it would still be required
to be in the west of the district but it
may be a different site that is
ultimately identified the council may be
required to look at sites that had
previously been
rejected future of our
towns the council is producing area
action plans for Rochford and Ry Town
centers these will be used to guide and
manage future development and include
policies against which any future
planning applications will be
considered both area action plans aim to
ensure the town centers are safe
accessible high quality places for
residents and visitors and conserve
their positive
characteristics the aim is for the
majority of businesses to be retail but
with an appropriate balance of other
uses including restaurants and cafes the
Rochford area action plan is at an
advanced stage it has been submitted for
examin ation and public hearing sessions
with the government inspector have taken
place he then asked the council to come
up with specifics for the future of
Market Square the council asked your
views and we are now reviewing your
suggestions next we will draw up some
suggested modifications to the plan
which will be subject to
consultation the ra area action plan was
subject to consultation earlier this
year we are currently reviewing the
results and expect to submit the plan
for government examination in the
Autumn further details can be found
online at www.ford.com
planning policy
team have your say we want to hear your
views on proposed modifications to two
plans which are set to affect the
district by midday on September the 25th
2014 the London Southend airport and
Environ joint area action plan
jaap this includes policies for
developing the airport and new business
space which together could create
thousands of much-needed jobs for the
area it also includes environment
enhancements as well as transport
improvements and regeneration
proposals the development management
plan this sets out the detailed
day-to-day policies which planning
applications will be assessed against it
includes for example policies for new
homes housing extension limits in the
green belt and equestrian
facilities it does not replace the core
strategy or allocation
plan this is how you can get involved
both of these plans have been subject to
extensive consultation and public
examination by a government inspector
several changes have now been made which
are referred to as the shedule of
modifications we want to know if these
address the issues people have raised in
each case the inspector will only be
considering comments on the
modifications and not other aspects of
the plans the sh schedule of
modifications for both plans is
available to view on the council's
website at
www.ford.com
can be made using these links
www.ford.com AAP for the
jaap the official representation forms
can be obtained from Council offices or
by phone on
0172 3181
91 local economy our first Parish Summit
more than 60 people attended the First
Parish and Town Council Summit hosted by
Rochford District Council as part of
efforts to work together in the
interests of
residents the event was organized by the
council's economic development team to
encourage better communication between
the district parish and town councils so
that we can work more closely together
it also provided a forum for councils to
learn from each other's experience to
the benefit of all those who live and
work in the district chairman of
Rochford district council councelor Mrs
Jun lumbley said Rochford is facing some
challenging issues and it is important
that we work in Partnership to ensure
that local local communities can be
actively involved and influence local
decisions and local Service
delivery it was really encouraging to
see all the attendees contributing and
engaging in this event everyone knows
the current challenging Financial
landscape for public services and I was
really impressed by the willingness of
the parish and town councils to step up
and consider the things that are most
important to local people delegates at
the summit heard from a range of guests
speakers including Essex police rspb and
Specialists from Rochford District
Council planning and economic
development teams as well as the
speakers there was also a range of
workshops on communication and training
emergency planning Environmental
Services initiatives and funding local
highways neighborhood planning groups
and
tourism funds to ease congestion
Rochford District Council has well
welcomed a growth deal which will bring
£42.4 million of investment to the
southeast with some of the funding set
to bolster plans for the area around
London Southend airport the funding
package was secured by the southeast
local Enterprise partnership and will
improve transport links in the areas it
covers Essex South End thurk East Sussex
Kent and Medway along with providing
investment to colleges and training
providers and a streamlined service to
businesses locally residents will
benefit from planned improvements to the
bell and Kent elm's interchanges on the
a127 facilitating access to London South
End airport and the new Saxon Business
Park of Cherry Orchard Way as proposed
in the Southend Airport an Environ joint
area action plan known as
jaap the leader of Rochford District
Council and chairman of Ten's Gateway
South essic partnership councelor Terry
cutmore said this growth deal is great
news for Rochford residents as it will
greatly improve transport links
enhancing our plans for the wider area
around London South End
airport improvements to this East West
Corridor including the fair Glenn
interchange should help encourage
businesses to take up the forthcoming
offer of Saxon Business Park which is
expected to generate 6,000 jobs as any
business worth its salt would want to
locate somewhere with good transport
links the enhancements will also
encourage through traffic and traffic
from the east of Rochford district and
South End burra to use the main arterial
route as opposed to trying to fight its
way along the minor roads that serve our
Villages councilor cutmore added in the
Rochford District residents will feel
the KnockOn effect of improvements
planned for South End particularly as
the revitalization of Victoria Avenue
will help to take pressure off the
housing demand generally for this
peninsula there will also be indirect
benefits for Rochford residents in
improving the road infrastructure along
the temps Corridor facilitating
connections to the main Motorway system
The increased traffic emanating from the
New London Gateway Port will also be
accommodated by this funding with
further Government funding and
Investments being brought forward on an
annual
basis Independence Day an Independence
Day initiative was held across the
district on July the fourth to Champion
our local retailers the colors of red
white and blue were proudly displayed in
shop windows in Rochford Ry and hawkley
to show appreciation to those who
continued to support their local
shopping areas our local parish and town
councils chambers of trade and local
independent Traders also joined forces
with Rochford District Council to
provide various activities and events
alongside the event Rochford District
council's economic development team ran
a Best Dressed window competition the
winners for Ry were Daisy lanes and Fab
shop Hawley was sunrise health and
Rochford was the faith store for more
information on how the economic
development team at Rochford District
Council can help support local
businesses telephone
31860 or email business at Rochford
dogo.com
in a Dragon's Den style business
challenge during an event organized by
Rochford District Council and Enterprise
in education the competition was the
grand finale of The Young Enterprise
scheme an initiative that aims to
support a more enter enterprising
culture amongst young people by
developing the skills and awareness
needed to Succeed in Business teams of
year 10 students from King Edmund School
greenswood Academy and the Fitz Yark
School worked together to invent an idea
to attract new business and tourists to
Rochford whilst meeting the needs of its
Community the winning team consisted of
pupils from the King Edmond School who
had invented an internet cafe offering
food and social media facilities in one
place to attract younger customers
Summit for flood issues Rochford
District Council has set up a new group
to address local flood related
issues the forum for surface water
flooding issues brings together
organizations including Essex County
Council flood management team anglian
water Essex highways and the environment
agency for round the table
discussion flooding issues are not the
responsibility of Rochford District
Council however this new group aims to
find out who is responsible for carrying
out various flood prevention measures in
order to try to ensure these
responsibilities are complied with Essex
County Council has also made available
an extra1 million pound of emergency
funding for Highway flooding hotspots
across the county Rochford District
Council was asked to produce a list of
our five most affected locations where
Essex County Council has now either
begun or is due to carry out work these
are beneath the railway Bridges at Spar
Road in
hawkley Church Road in Hawley and Hall
Rochford watery Lane in hullbridge
and Barling Road near to Kings meat
Cottages in
Barling the list does not contain major
Junctions such as Ry Weir and The
fairglen Interchange as these are
covered under separate
plans work has also been carried out at
hedg Hope Avenue and fair me in Ry which
consisted of pipe laying works the
clearance of vegetation and removal of
debris Watford District Council had
previously budgeted
£18,000 towards tackling surface water
draining issues this will now be
eligible for a match funding offer from
Essex County Council who are offering up
to
50,000 to tackle local flooding issues
to report a blocked Gully or Highway
drainage
issues call Essex highways on 0845
6376 31 and here's some flooding advice
for further information on how to
prepare for possible flooding visit the
web link which I'll give you in a second
or two and this includes an interactive
map showing the areas at risk from
surface water flooding you need to go to
www.gov.uk forward slash prepare for a
flood forward slash
find out if you're at risk if you are
flooded or in imminent danger of
flooding during a storm you should
contact the Essex fire and rescue
service on
999 if you are unfortunate enough to be
flooded there is very helpful advice on
what to do next in the flood re recovery
guide written by people who have had
firsthand experience of flooding and you
can find that at
www. noou flood risk.
co.uk forward slash
sites forward slash
default SL files
forfood recovery
guidor
interactive.
PDF parking charges change parking
charges have increased in Council pay
and display car Parks as a result of
budget constraints however the council
will be keeping free Saturday afternoon
parking in these car parks parking
charges were also introduced for all
blue badge holders to ensure the council
complies with the equalities act 2010
the ACT requires all blue badge holders
to be treated equally when concessions
are granted as previously only those
with Road tax exemption parked free
the changes mean all blue badge holders
will now be required to pay for parking
however provided the blue badge is
displayed in the vehicle they will now
be granted a 1-hour concession beyond
the expiry time printed on their pay and
display ticket to account for mobility
issues no changes have been made to
parking charges at the approach car park
or hawkley Woods car park or to season
tickets the maximum length of stay The
Old Ship Lane Car Park has been extended
from 2 hours to
4 to pay for parking by mobile phone
Rochford District Council has changed
its service provider to pay by phone and
the new number to call is
47275 alternatively you can text rge
reeg followed by a space and then your
vehicle registration number to
6565 or go to
www.paybyphone.com
to register your details or you can
download the free paybyphone
app District boundary review The
Independent local government boundary
commission for England is carrying out
an electoral review of Rochford District
Council the review will draw new Council
Ward boundaries across the District the
commission has also announced that it is
minded to recommend that 39 counselors
should continue to be elected to the
council in
future now they are asking for evidence
about your local area to help them
decide a new pattern of council Wards
for Rochford District Council your views
will make a difference local people know
their area best that's why they are
asking you for evidence on a range of
issues do you have suggestions about
where your ward boundaries should be
which areas do you identify as your
local community where do people in your
area go to access local facilities such
as shops and leisure activities for more
details and interactive maps visit
www.c consultation.
lgb.org
or
www.c.org
have your say send your views to the
review officer Rochford local government
boundary commission for England Leen
house turnmill Street London ec1 M5
LG or email reviews at
lgb.org
do.uk or follow them on Twitter at
lgbc the consultation closes on
September the 29th 2014
Rochford and Castle Point Sports annual
Awards for 2014 are sponsored by
Pinnacle
PSG the categories and
criteria all nominees must either live
within the Rochford District or burough
of Castle point or be a current and
competing or participating member of a
sports club based within either area or
go to school in either area in the case
of sports club of the year the club must
be based within the Rochford District or
burough of Castle
point the achievements referred to must
be between the 1st of October
2013 and the 30th of September this year
but this does exclude people in the
services to sport categ
category categories are Rochford
District sports Personality of the Year
sponsored by Wells legal solicitors the
disability sports Personality of the
year is sponsored by Waters and Stanton
limited the young sports Personality of
the Year sponsored by Southend United
Community and educational
trust in the burough of Castle Point as
we've already said services to sport
they're sponsored by The Cooperative
funeral care and more information about
how to do that I will tell you about in
a second or two sports club of the Year
sponsored by Fusion lifestyle Rochford
Castle Point 2012 respect award is
sponsored by Affinity
1777 those candidates who are
shortlisted for awards will be contacted
by the thir 13th of October this year
and invited to the award ceremony which
will take place on the evening of the
6th of November at running me Hall in
benfleet winners in each category will
receive an engraved trophy Shield
certificate and a check for
£100 now if you'd like a nomination form
you could contact Mark alus R cpsa
Rochford District Council Council
Offices South Street Rochford Essex ss41
BW or you could submit a nomination form
online at
www.ford.com architecture and culture
during the Heritage Open days buildings
of every age style and function throw
open their doors giving visitors a
chance to discover architectural
treasures and enjoy a wide range of
Tours events and activities that bring
local history and culture to life the Ry
windmill is no exception it's
award-winning volunteers dressed up in
traditional period costume and offered
guided tours reminding us why they
deserve to win the museums and Heritage
2014 award for customer service
Excellence joining the Ry windmill in
the celebrations where local charity ra
through the Looking Glass together with
the Rochford and District Community
archives who exhibited at the rawi hall
alongside artist Richard arent and
author Ian
yley Ry windmill is nearing its 200th
wedding booking to celebrate this
Rochford District Council is offering
one lucky couple the hire of rayy
windmill free of charge for their
wedding to find out more please contact
the council's Leisure team on
01702 546 366 or email leure atford.com
project delivered by Rochford District
Council in partnership with Castle Point
burrow Council active Rochford and
active Castle point the project will see
local businesses and access free sport
and physical activity sessions launch
days giving staff information on how
they can get involved have proved very
popular and activities to be delivered
in year one include badminton fencing
and swimming great wakering primary
school has already already enjoyed a
Pilates taster and cricet has been set
up for macro staff for further
information phone
01702 31
8121 or email
sportford
dogovor
20134 Rochford District Council produces
an annual report which gives an overview
of the council's performance spending
and financial position the full report
is available on our website but here is
an overview of what projects we've spent
money on and how much we've
spent the council produces a detailed
incomeon expenditure account which can
be found in the statement of accounts
and it's set out in a prescribed manner
however here is some information about
each of the corporate objectives and and
the amount showing the cost of the
services and what's left to be financed
from the local and national tax
income the net expenditure
20134 and there these are in millions of
pounds we start with making a difference
to our community this includes
collection of local taxes council tax
and housing benefits emergency planning
and health and safety Leisure and Sports
Development Housing Services and
homelessness and Community safety
elections local land charges cemeteries
and
churchyards
Licensing public
conveniences and Democratic services
that all accounted for
6.34
million making a difference to our
environment
mil Tower windmill Woodlands parks and
Open Spaces Planning and Building
control environmental health Street
cleansing recycling
44.83
million making a difference to our local
economy economic development and car
Parks
.45 million the net cost of services is
11.62 million less the statutory
accounting adjustments including Capital
charges this is a minus amount of
1.41 less income from cash Investments
0.06 plus money put into reserves for
future use
0.07 a cost of local services to be met
by local and National taxes giving a
total of
10.22 the net cost of services last year
that's
20123 was
11.38 million and this is illustrated by
the corporate objective and this
follows what did we spend last year Well
making a difference to our community
5.75 million making a difference to our
environment
5.73 million making a difference to our
local economy this was a credit of
0.10 so the net cost of services was
11.38 million now where did the money
come from well the 10.2 million that we
spent on providing local Services after
contributions from reserves and income
raised from various fees and charges it
came from local and National taxes and
redistributed business
rates our total income for the year was
10.22 million as opposed to the year
20123 which was 10.27 Million which was
split 2.7 million in government grants
1.62 million from National business
rates returned to the council and 5.9
million from council tax residents and
I'll show you now how that was split up
26% came from government grants 16% of
it came from business rates and 58% of
it came from council
tax and for a summary of income and
expenditure the council has been using
balances built up over previous years to
cover some of the reduction in
Government funding and these must now be
built up again so for the year
201314 the revenue account Surplus total
income was in deficit of 10.22 million
the total cost of services was
10.11 Million so the surus for the year
Well there wasn't one
0.11 in the
red delivering value for money during
20134 the council has been successful in
generating income through the provision
of services to Partners and other
councils and approximately
$132,400 has been earned from objectives
such as providing a payroll service to
Castle point and Trust
Administration working in Partnership on
legal services and building control
providing grounds maintenance services
to parish councils and Essex County
Council the council also planned to make
savings during the year of
420,000 which were delivered this has
been achieved by more efficient service
and better organization Rochford
District council's dedicated staff
continue to work hard to ensure it
offers its residents value for money
some examples of saving are intensive
testing on benefits was carried out by
internal audit instead of the external
Auditors new contract arrangements for
the grounds maintenance service over
100,000 per year in savings from a new
ICT contract and reduction in the cost
of external audit the council is
determined to deliver high levels of
performance Rochford has shown that
despite having one of the lowest
government grant funding levels it
continues to save money and reduce
spending we will continue to keep close
scrutiny over Council
money council tax the council was
responsible for collecting 44.1 million
P of council tax last year but we only
kept 5.9 million equivalent to 13p in
every one pound collected the majority
of what's collected is paid to others as
follows parish and town councils 1.1
million Essex Fire Authority 1.9 million
Essex police Authority 4.1 million
Rochford District Council 5.9 million
Essex County Council a £
31.1
million the reduction in the amount of
council tax collected was due to the
government's introduction of a local
council tax support scheme which gives a
discount to eligible claimants instead
of paying a council tax
benefit the average council tax for
baned D property for
201314 was made up as follows Rochford
District Council
£211 Essex County Council
8675 Essex fire and rescue £66 42 Essex
police Authority 1414 48 town and Parish
councils average
£395 giving a total of
1,538 191 and in 2013 the national
average for council tax on a baned d
property was £
1,456 discretionary rate relief
Charities and some sports clubs are
entitled to 80% mandatory relief on
their business rates in order to provide
additional support the council can award
discretionary relief for the remaining
20% for 201314 discretionary relief was
awarded to 31 organizations throughout
the district at a cost of the Council of
9,457 capital expenditure we also spend
money on improving land and buildings in
order to continue delivering excellent
costeffective services for all our
customers capital expenditure is the
money spent on the purchase and
Improvement of buildings Vehicles
equipment and computer software it is
called capital expenditure as it results
in assets which the council and the
community can use for more than one year
capital expenditure does not directly
affect the council tax for 20134 our
expenditure on Capital compared to what
we planned to spend was as follows and
this is in thousands of
pounds what we spent vehicles and
equipment planned
544000 actual was
128,000 Leisure and play facilities 220
and 148 disabled housing grants
425 it infrastructure 47 and that was
the same for actual Council properties
296 and
154 big Society grants 49 and actual was
48 the total 1, 649,000
planned and actual was £950,000
some of the projects not completed in
201314 will be rolled forward into
201415 the £950,000 which was spent on
our land and property assets was paid
for by Capital receipts from the sale of
property grants and from reeven
Revenue how we paid for capital
expenditure
20134 grants and contributions
190,000 Capital receipts £
760,000 making a total of £950,000
financial performance Rochford District
Council is amongst the best in Essex and
the country when it comes to collecting
council tax the revenues and benefits
team collected
98.3% of the 4 4.1 million council tax
due last year we also collected 97.8% of
business rates due last year which was
an increase on 2012 13 collecting income
in the current economic climate is
challenging but staff have offered as
much support and advice as possible to
help local residents and businesses to
pay their
bills and some environment information
now waste not want not the there's a
recycling event called rethink rubbish
and that's taking place on Thursday the
30th of October from 11:00 a.m. to 300
p.m. at the mil arts and Event Center in
Ry now if you're looking for a free
familyfriendly day to keep the kids
occupied this Autumn then why not head
to the first rethink rubbish event which
is being held as part of an ongoing
Drive to get everyone
recycling the event will be a
celebration of the district's recycling
achievement as we are currently number
one in the whole of England for our
recycling rates it also marks 10 years
since the first curbside recycling
scheme was put in place for the district
so at Rochford District Council we would
like to take the opportunity to thank
all residents for for their enthusiasm
and participation in the various
recycling schemes throughout the past
decade the event will consist of a
variety of recycling and reuse
activities along with information on all
things
recycling children will get the chance
to take part in Fabric and recycl called
Art workshops which will involve making
a weave and a large scale
collage then enjoy some recycled rhythms
a performance by pupils from downhall
primary school reallyy working with the
mushroom theater company which will
involve using old pots pans metal bins
and other recycled Goods to make music
children will also be able to try their
hands at some of the instruments after
the
performance during the afternoon you'll
be able to Feast your eyes on a
spectacular fashion show using recycled
and reused clothing the show has been
created by students from cic college and
Fitz y Mark School ra especially for the
day for the adults there will be
information on reducing food waste
Reuse Recycling and sewing workshops
where you can learn how to make do and
mend old items of clothing to give them
new lease of life Eco businesses and
Community groups will also be in
attendance to give you an overview of
their work teams from Rochford District
Council and Essex County Council will be
present to answer any waste and
recycling questions so why not pop in to
the mil arts and event center raay from
11:00 a.m. to 300 p.m. Thursday the 30th
of October and there's no need to
book now please
don't be confused by curbside recycling
anymore these items can go into your
curbside recyclables
bin yogurt pot base plastic food tray
base and carrier
bags what about those that can't well
yogurt pot lids cling film crisp packets
film lid from a food tray salad bag
baguette wrapper supermarket food bags
you know there's little plastic ones
that you can get off a roll to put your
loose fruit and veg in
also these non-recyclable items must be
placed in your non-recyclables
bin cling film bubble
wrap plastic wrapping black Sachs
chocolate Crispen biscuit wrappers
polyyne disposable
nappies incontinence pads pants sanitary
waste cat litter and animal
feces pet food cat food pouches animal
bedding vacuum dust used tissues cotton
wool cotton buds corks pots pans and
Cutlery wood
non-reusable textiles in other words
textiles that are heavily soiled and if
you'd like more information visit
www.ford.com
to clean up after their pets with people
saying dog fowling is the most offensive
form of litter people are becoming far
less tolerant of dog fowling and are
more likely to challenge someone if they
see them not scooping The Poop part of
the responsibility that goes with owning
a dog is to clear up after its mess
whilst the majority of dog owners do
pick up some inconsiderate people are
leaving dogs mess in parks on Pavements
and in Alleyways and this is Being
Stepped On by school children other
residents are Wheeling push chairs and
mobility scooters through it and it then
ends up in people's homes to tackle this
problem the council has developed an
educational program to highlight the
issue and to warn individuals that they
run the risk of a fine if they fail to
clear up after their dog a poster
competition was also carried out with
children at Great wakering primary
school and Riverside Primary School
hullbridge who came up with creative
ideas about how to encourage people
people to pick up after their Pooch
please look out for our notices on the
Pavements and warning posters which are
being used in problem areas in the
Rochford District our officers will be
out patrolling these areas so if you
know of a problem with dog fowling
please report it to the
council report it to sort it a love
clean streets mobile phone application
can be downloaded for free as part of
efforts to keep our environment ship
shape the application lets you take a
photo and will automatically find where
you are and send the location and image
straight to the council's street scene
team for residents in the district the
app makes it easier to report Street
cleansing issues and for the council it
means we're able to respond quicker to
clear up the problem you simply download
the app for free from your smartphone
App Store look for love clean streets
select the Rochford CA version then hit
download then when you see a street
cleansing issue you want to report take
out your phone take a photo of it and
the application will send it straight to
the council Please be aware although the
app is free of charge reporting a
problem is charged at the usual data
rates for sending photos within your
mobile data
tariff volunteers lend a hand volunteers
have been clearing streams and building
dams in an effort to help reduce the
risk of flooding employees from South
McDonald's have been working with staff
from Rochford district council at Hawley
Woods where they have cleared the stream
by removing branches and debris which
had been stopping the flow of water dams
have also been built to allow natural
pools to form to catch Surplus rain
waterer which will prevent flooding
further Downstream Rochford District
council's head of Environmental Services
Richard Evans said this is one of many
environmental projects we have worked on
with McDonald's in south end it is very
encouraging that they have such a vested
interest in our district the work all
our volunteers do is greatly appreciated
and we would encourage anyone who wants
to volunteer for environmental projects
to contact our street scene team on
31811 out and about who what when where
and how we'll start with clubs and
groups events at Rochford Library
Wishing Well Center every Tuesday 9:45
to 10:15 a.m. stories and rhymes for
babies and
toddlers the job Club every Thursday
between 2: and 4:00 p.m. help building
your CV searching and applying for
vacancies a baby and toddler group every
Friday 930 to 10 a.m. stories and rhymes
for not to 5 years a book sale every
Saturday all day what will you discover
dial every last Tuesday each month 10:30
a.m. to 1:30 p.m. disability information
and advice and Care Mark every last
Thursday each month 10:00 a.m. to 12:
noon advice on care and support at
home Southend wad Kai
traditional W Rayo keeping to the
original teachings of its founder honori
otsuka at Great wakering Memorial Hall
on Mondays at 7 and St Andrews Church
Hall ashington on Fridays at 7 contact
Tony Brooker
7 art classes suitable for beginners and
and more experienced students Mondays
and Tuesdays 10:00 a.m. until 12 and 1
p.m. till 3 at the women's Institute
Hall Bellingham Lane
Ry contact is
01702 615
475 or you could email Paul alock
43 at
yahoo.co.uk B Minton the club are
anxious to recruit experienced players
they meet every Monday evening from 7:30
until
9:30 at the David Cox Sports Hall Fitz y
Mark School Ry the contact is Fitz y
Mark Badminton Club Mark worship
71914 His email worships at talk talkt
talk.net
Nordic walking a fun walking session
using polls to increase your workout no
experience necessary Tuesdays at 11:00
a.m. Cherry Orchard Park but booking is
essential please contact active life
Tina
2395 there's a website
www. activ life .
uk.com
The Institute of advanced motorists this
friendly local group meets meets to
discuss motoring and road safety issues
they meet on the first Wednesday evening
over every other month at hotley
Community Center the contact is Colin
gamon you can find him on
20476 roach art group all abilities are
catered For at this friendly club with
good lighting and facilities and a
variety of media they meet on Wednesday
evenings between 7:30 p.m. and 9:30 p.m.
at St Theresa's Church Hall ashington
Road Rochford ss41 RF the entrance is
via the school gates with a hall located
to the rear of the church reasonable
fees apply and details on request from
Jill
07968 745
975 or John
26393 active 50 plus a fun exercise
session for all abilities to increase
the heart rate and tone up Fridays
9:30 hawkwell Baptist
church4 per session no need to book just
come along and join in the uh contact is
active life Sarah
62626 again website
www.active.com
the roach art group annual exhibition is
on from 10 a.m. m. to 400 p.m. on
Saturday the 25th of October at St
Theresa's Church
hall9 ashington Road Rochford ss41 RF
and the entrance is via the school Gates
it's free admission and free parking and
I'll give you Jill's number again that's
07968 745 975 or John on
0793 26
3930 Council and committee meetings all
meetings will take place at the Civic
Suite to Hawley Road R ss6 8eb and they
all start at 7:30
pm. development committee Thursday
September the 25th audit committee
Tuesday September the 30th standards
committee Tuesday October the 2nd review
Comm committee Tuesday October the 7th
the executive Wednesday October the 15th
full council meeting Tuesday October the
21st development committee Thursday
October the 30th Review Committee
Tuesday November the 4th the executive
Wednesday November the 5th development
committee Thursday November the 20th for
more information call member services on
31814 the Arts Family Theater these are
professional theater shows for Children
and Families which are fun entertaining
and
affordable 2 p.m. on Sunday October the
12th Fireside tales with
Granddad 2 p.m. Sunday November the 9th
the magic porridge pot both at the M
arts and events center Ry and just £350
per ticket to book Rochford District
Council customer services
01702 3181
91 and some dates for your diary
Rochford Art Trail from September the
18th to the
27th half-term holiday activities
October the 27th to the 3st and Rochford
and Castle Point sports awards November
the 6th
Sports and
Leisure Rochford District disability
Sports sessions taster sessions in
bottia sitting volleyball and table
Cricket for all ages these are at
stanbridge Parish Hall ss4 2 a and all
sessions are free of charge and these
are the times and dates 10:00 a.m. to
12: noon on Wednesday September the 24th
2: to 4:00 p.m. on Friday October the
3rd 6: to 8:00 p.m. on Wednesday October
the 8th all participants are welcome to
attend at any time throughout the 2
hours for more information phone
31812 or you can email sport
atford.com the sessions please contact
us so we can discuss what assistance we
may be able to
provide and please note that although
events are checked before going to press
they are subject to change we recommend
you visit our website at www.ford.com
sign up for paperless billing visit
www.ford.com and we will do the rest for
you 24/7 access to our online
services revenues and benefits have been
working hard to update our section of
Rochford District council's website
making it easier for customers to find
out about our services the website is
now more informative userfriendly and
help customers to help themselves by
visiting our website you can use our
online services to view your council tax
business rate or housing Benefit
Accounts report a move make payments
sign up for direct debits and paperless
billing and download application forms
and advice
leaflets useful information for revenues
and benefits customers is as follows
www.ford.com council tax you can find
out how to use our online services how
your bill is calculated how to pay what
happens if you don't pay what to do if
you are moving about discounts and
exemptions about local council tax
support how to appeal and how to contact
us
www.ford.com welfare reform changes
discretionary housing payments and
overpaid housing benefit how to report
suspected fraud how to appeal and how to
contact us
www.ford.com
in Focus chairman pays
tribute the 100-year anniversary of the
start of the first world war was
commemorated on Monday August the 4th
with acts of remembrance held across the
district the Ry windmill hosted an
exhibition showing what life was like in
Ry at the outbreak of the war the
exhibition organized by local charity ra
Through the Looking Glass in conjunction
with with Rochford District Community
archives displayed photographs of the
Town taken in
1914 it also featured the records and
family photos of 204 ra men who fought
in the conflict including 92 who sadly
never returned Ry Through the Looking
Glass volunteer Mike Davis said we spend
a lot of our time researching the
history of Ry and obviously the Great
War is a significant part of this it is
only right and proper that we commend
the sacrifices made by the ra men who
fought in the
conflict councilor June Lumley chairman
of Rochford District Council said I am
honored and humbled to have attended
this
exhibition looking through all the items
on display it really brings it home the
sacrif Rices people made to protect
their
country the volunteers have all done an
amazing job and I would like to
personally thank them for the time and
effort they have put into the exhibition
to make it the success it is it was
great to see the windmill full of people
of all ages coming together to remember
the Local Heroes of our past and
teaching the younger Generations just
how important they were were and still
are to us
today and remember you can invite the
chairman to attend events in the
district she's very keen to meet as many
groups and organizations as she can
across the district during her year in
office so she can better understand the
valuable work that they do in particular
for people who are vulnerable and need
additional help and support to improve
the quality of their lives the chairman
councelor Jun Lumley has decided decided
at this stage not to name any Charities
to support until the end of her year but
they will be local charities within the
Rochford District she's open to
invitations to visit schools in the
district and with Christmas coming up
will be very pleased to attend any Carol
concerts being arranged at local
schools the chairman recently attended
the disability essics first exhibition
the only way is disability essics which
was a Showcase of products and services
available to disabled people in their
daily lives the event was held on July
the 4th Independence Day so was themed
striving for Independence she was
delighted to attend saying that it was
interesting to see the type of products
and services now available to disabled
people to give them greater
Independence if you'd like the chairman
to attend an event please phone the
Civic office officer Lynn Rackley on
3181 44 or email lin. Rackley atford.com
back in May Rochford District Council
was already starting to prepare to
commemorate the start of the first world
war by planting poppy seeds at various
spots throughout the district the former
chairman and our young citizen of the
Year Luke Polly both attended a ceremony
at Ry wi where they led a service
honoring those who lost their lives
during during the four years of the war
and planted the poppy seeds in
remembrance with August the 4th being
the anniversary of the start of the
first world war the new chairman paid a
visit to the windmill to see the poppies
in full bloom the chairman councelor Jun
lumbley said it's wonderful to see that
all the poppies have flowered just in
time to remember those who lost their
lives 100 years ago the council
currently has plans for a 4-year program
of events from 2014 to 2018 to
commemorate the Cent of the first world
war D-Day hero
remembers memories from Survivor of
Pegasus bridge and accompanying this
article is a wonderful photograph of Pat
Topsy Turner who was the gentleman
involved with his
medals he was 14 pilot B company ox and
bucks in glider
3 Pat Turner is a Survivor from the
Pegasus Bridge Invasion and he lives
right here in the Rochford District to
celebrate this great man we asked him to
recall his memories from that fateful
night and share with the district just
how important the mission was this is
his
story until recently I never really
understood how important this operation
was to the overall success of the
invasion and I doubt whether many of the
other soldiers realized
either we had our orders we'd been very
well trained when the time came in
common with thousands of others we just
did what was expected of us I would like
to take this opportunity to make the
point that it is nothing I repeat
nothing like the way it has been
portrayed in the
movies when when the action started as
it did just after midnight it was Pitch
Black with just the occasional glint off
the water and the vaguest of vague
outlines of buildings trees and of
course the bridge after the first flare
went up from the German side there
commenced an intense period of guns
being fired stun and Mills grenades
going off and lots and lots of noise
shouting and shadowy forms running about
the scene was lit eerily by the flicker
of the flares and muzzle flashes and
possibly by the distant explosions of
our tow planes bombing Cayenne 6
kilometers away to the West although to
be
honest I can't remember that exactly as
I tended to be a bit busy at the time
think of a crowd fitfully and
intermittently lit up at a fireworks
display and you have part of the
picture we had left tarant Rushton
Airfield in Dorset late that evening and
after an hour and a half our Pilots had
cast off from the towing bombers over
the coast and we and number three glider
headed for the Canal Bridge following
the other two gliders at one minute
intervals not that you could see them it
was all done with watches and dead Rec
Reckoning we became very quiet in the
glider as we approached the landing
which was basically a semi-controlled
crash at about 100 m an hour as we were
so heavily
overloaded I was typical of the other 28
men in our glider my normal weight was
10 and a half Stone but with the extra
ammunition and equipment I was carrying
I weighed in at 17 and a half stone that
night just as we were about to land the
order was given link arms which we did
at the same time raising our feet from
the floor there was a huge crunching and
cracking sound as the glider floor
collapsed and the wing broke off truth
to tell I don't remember anymore until I
found myself with the others outside the
wreck of the glider with all the noise
and commotion that I mentioned earlier
around us the time was just
0018 the sappers with us were given
priority to look for the demolition
explosives that were supposed to be on
the bridge when they announced all clear
the rest of us gave them a cheer and
strange as it may seem a round of
applause I later noticed a body in the
water of the swamp that we had landed
alongside and like everyone else had
assumed it was a
German but it turned out to be my mate
and number one to my number two on the
Bren gun Fred
greenhous possibly the first man to
actually die on
D-Day it turned out that he'd been
thrown out of our glider when it split
apart on landing and drowned
in the adjacent
swamp after beating off several German
counter attacks we were relieved later
in the morning by the troops coming up
from the beaches where they had landed
earlier and I'm not ashamed to admit it
that quite a few of us were emotionally
upset by the relief from the tension and
the knowledge that we had done it in
summary I can only say that for me me
and I suspect many others it was a night
of confusion intense feelings and stress
but because of the superb training we
made fewer mistakes than the enemy
thereby enabling the battle to be
brought to a successful
conclusion the lights go out a lights
out campaign has been held to
commemorate the day Britain declared war
on Germany on August the 4th
1914 as a nation we were all encouraged
to extinguish all lights in our homes
and public buildings leaving just one
lamp or candle a light in a window
between the hours of 10 p.m. and 11:00
p.m. as a symbol of reflection and hope
at this time more than a million
Commonwealth service Personnel who lost
their lives in the first world war were
remembered the council was pleased to
participate in this event turning all
our lights out at the old house Rochford
the Civic Suite Ry and at rley Windmill
apart from one lamp the council's
chairman Jun Lumley also attended a
candle lit service held by the Royal
British Legion ra Branch at their
memorial in London Hill Church
Street environment explore our Parks
situated in the rolling Countryside of
the roach Valley Cherry Orchard Jubilee
country Country Park lies in some of the
most beautiful countryside in South
Essex this 200 acre Wildlife Park
continues to mature providing a unique
space for residents and visitors to
enjoy the park is taking shape out of a
vision of turning an area of Farmland
into a public open space where everyone
can enjoy all the countryside has to
offer there are numerous public rights
of way for Walkers cyclists and horse
riders to enjoy areas of open grassland
have been established and these are moan
to create more varied species Rich
Meadows the first phase the central
section of the park has been completed
with the planting of 28,000 native trees
a surfaced bridal way allows good access
to the lake and other areas of the park
for horse riders cyclists and
walkers in 2008 the council acquired
further land and Woodland to the east
and west of the existing Park seven new
Woodlands of more than 35 Acres contain
containing 32,000 trees were planted
that winter recent years has seen the
addition of a car park play area Orchard
and Wild Flower Meadow funding
opportunities to allow continued
Improvement to our Open Spaces are
proving more challenging to find and
this may continue for some time with the
council's commitment to preserving our
local landscape whatever the future
holds One Thing Remains a constant the
the freedom for us all and future
generations to enjoy this beautiful part
of
Essex in Focus forgotten
fruits recent years have seen an
increased interest in the restoration of
England's once abundant and productive
Orchards Essex in particular has lost
75% of its original
Orchards from the outset it had been
planned to create a community Orchard
within Cherry Orchard Jubilee Country
Park using where possible local Essex
varieties of apple pear and Cherry the
young trees were purchased from the east
of England apples and Orchards project
Nursery an organization which is
dedicated to the restoration of our
Count's
Orchards the cherry trees a mix of East
Anglia varieties have been planted
outside the main Orchard to create an
area to picnic and play and you may also
enjoy the fruit if you can get to it
before the
birds the oldest Essex dessert Apple we
have planted is dsy spice
1785 and culinary Apple Dr Harvey dates
back to
1629 with such enchanting names who
could resist the temptation to to try
these forgotten fruits thank you to the
Friends group members who helped with
planting on a cold December morning and
also to Bruce Reed who generously shared
his knowledge of fruit trees why not
join us and celebrate All Things apple
on Apple day which is Sunday September
the 28th this year we will have an apple
expert on hand to identify your own
apples who knows you may have a lost
Variety in your own back
Garden in March 2010 a friends of Cherry
Orchard Jubilee Country Park group was
formed the friends group allows the
local community to have a say in how the
park is managed as they are the users of
these facilities they best place to say
what is needed in the park in addition
to this they organize events in the park
such as nature walks and fun dayss you
may be familiar with the very successful
apple day a free fun family festival
with lots to see and do for all ages as
we've heard this year it will be held
from 11:00 a.m. to 400 p.m. on Sunday
September the 28th there will be food
entertainment and lots of familyfriendly
activities if you'd like to know more
about Apple day or joining the friends
of Cherry Orchard Jubilee Country Park
please visit ww w.f friends ofer Orchard
park.org or you can find the friends
group on
Facebook Halloween don't be mean
Halloween seems to be one of those
things like Marmite that people either
love or loathe if you love it it's a
great opportunity to dress up carve your
pumpkin decorate your home in a ghoulish
way and get out there to trick or treat
on all Hallow's Eve this October 31st
for those of you you with children there
are some good safety tips on the TW
smart website at
www.to smart.
co.uk Halloween Essex police will be
making sure everyone has a good time
without crossing the line so be sure not
to upset your neighbors by Behaving
Badly if you see a sign for no trick or
treaters don't knock on the door sadly
each year a small minority have thrown
eggs this can damage paintwork and
anyone found doing it will be dealt with
as causing antisocial behavior and
criminal damage if you loath it and
don't want any trick or treaters to come
to your door you can print off a sorry
no trick or treaters poster from the two
smart website or pick one up from Ry
police station Rochford District Council
Offices South Street in Rochford the
Civic Suite in Ry or your local
library if you have suffered an egging
wash it off as soon as possible to
prevent it C causing any damage if you
are concerned about any Behavior near
your home you can call police on 101 and
report it remember the vast majority of
children don't cause any problem and are
just seeking a treat most will be
accompanied by adults shopkeepers are
being asked to restrict the sale of eggs
and flour to young people in the week
running up to Halloween in a bid to
reduce damage to property posters will
be distributed for Traders to display in
their windows this year a local poster
competition will also be run with
schools on the theme trick or treat
let's stay
safe solving neighbor disputes a free
specialist mediation service to resolve
neighborhood disputes is available
across the Rochford district and Castle
Point
burough the mediation and advice project
a local Enterprise company has been
engaged to provide the service which has
been awarded funding from Castle point
and Rochford District Community safety
partnership sessions last up to two
hours and are led by a fully trained
mediator on average it takes two
sessions to come to a mutual agreement
the sessions are informal completely
confidential and can take place via
telephone or with face-to-face meetings
if you'd like to find out more you could
telephone
6795 or you could
email the me d a d project and that's
all one word at
cpc.org
a keep safe scheme is set to be launched
in the Rochford District so people know
where they can turn in a crisis
it means that certain places will be
designated as a keep safe venue where
any person who feels unwell upset or
disorientated can go to ask for help to
contact a family member friend or carer
local venues identified as safe places
will provide free access to a telephone
or will make a call on behalf of someone
producing their keep safe card each
venue will display a logo so they can be
easily
identified the keep safe scheme aimed at
the over 60s was first launched by brain
tree District Council and has been so
successful that it has been replicated
for residents in the Chelmsford CER
tendering and molden areas there are now
in excess of 100 keep safe venues across
Essex the local scheme will be launched
on October the 1st 2014 and will
initially be in Ry only if you would
would like your Venue to take part
contact Rochford District council's
Community safety team on
31812 free home safety checks these free
checks are being offered to those aged
over 65 or who require additional
support due to a learning disability or
mental physical or sensory impairment
they are provided by the community
safety team in partnership with Essex
County Council trading standards and
Essex County Fire and Rescue service and
include advice on fire safety dealing
with cold calling and using the buy with
confidence scheme to find reputable
Traders portable Appliance testing is
carried out on small electrical
appliances by a qualified electrician
and any item that fails will be fixed or
replaced free of charge smoke alarms
will also be provided and fitted free of
charge if deemed necessary to find out
more email Community safety Rochford
dogo.com